the gyro can experience has anyone
contacted you before this or since in
particular and asked for your advice as
to how they can better prepare like
columns of like the president oh the
president hasn't but I know a number of
the people working in the White House
and they oh yeah well you know I've
served roles in the last five
presidential administrations I worked
for two Republican governors two
Democratic governors as you appreciate
one dependent rasler I worked for two
when he was governor Jesse oh and and
that's right yeah and so you know I I've
never had a partisan you know I'm just a
private in the public health all right
and so I actually served as a science
envoy for this administration in the
State Department last year you know I'm
still in my full-time job at the
University and so I've never been I mean
I'm there to give the best advice I can
and so I've talked to a lot of these
people there at the CDC at Health Human
Services etc so yeah we've given a lot
of advice and do you think there's
anything that you could do now that
could help them make sure that we don't
have these shortages of masks and
shortages of medicine and IV bags and
something that could be done to I mean
you obviously you've laid out all these
problems yeah when you laid it out in
your book here the people goodbye right
now go pick it up on Amazon right video
version of it as well there is all right
do you read it I'd the book yes no you
know you know I have I don't know I
don't read my cell you know there's
actually a really good voice it's not
mine drives me crazy
ya know you know this is the challenge
we have is today in this environment
everything's just in time delivery I
mean look at when you mean you go online
and you whatever place your everything
from Amazon wherever you back to throw
the next day yeah people forget that we
don't have that capacity today to
suddenly make lots of things so right
now all the mass manufacturers in North
America are working 110% time but if
they were trying to fill all the orders
they've gotten just in the last few
weeks would take him years and years
with the capacity they have and you
can't build build these
new machines to make masks overnight so
this is something that should be set in
advance of anything like this any
pandemic happening like long in advance
we should be prepared you know think
about the issue as defense you know we
prepare all the time well in advance we
don't build an aircraft carrier at the
moment we think we're gonna go to the
battle we look at what all do we need we
don't do that in public health we've
tried and so you know what stockpiling
500 million of these in 95 s would have
been the difference between night and
day and when you look at the price of
one of those versus one airplane not
even close
if you look at the things like that it's
like these medications I don't think
about our own Defense Department
employees are at risk of running out of
these critical drugs because they get
them from China I mean what a
vulnerability yeah so what we need to do
is take a step back after when we can
start now but we're not going to fix it
now is to say what are the key things
that we should do vaccines you know if
we had been serious about this we might
very well have had a corona virus
vaccine that whether worked specifically
for this strain whether it worked for
SARS or MERS but right after SARS
happened in 2003 everybody was hot at a
new vaccine and then when it went away
the interest waned is it something like
the flu where you know sometimes when
they come up with a few a flu vaccine it
doesn't necessarily address the current
strain yeah it could be and that's where
a corona virus family vaccine may not
match up right here now but it could and
and the flu one you've really hit an
important point there's one where you
know we do have an imperfect vaccine but
it still does a lot of good you know
fifty percent of the people are
protected that's heck a lot better than
zero yeah if we had a vaccine right now
that fifty percent of the people could
be protected against this virus man
think of all the lives we'd save so the
bottom line message is we can't wait and
tell the crisis to fix these things you
know what we spend about point zero zero
zero one percent of public health
compared to our Defense Department and
yet look how vulnerable the it's the
bugs it's not a war yeah it's not a
missile is bringing down the world
economy right now and it's a darn virus
yeah and so this is where I think that's
what I tried to say in my book was all
about that I went into what we needed to
do and
I hate it when people come up and say
we're screwed you know my whole bottom
line is what are you gonna do about it
then and that's what I laid out a whole
plan in here like these vaccines like
the stockpiles of mass you know we
should have a plan in place already what
are we gonna do with our schools when
they close are we gonna really close
schools let's not try to make this on
the fly you know I just mentioned if we
close schools we're gonna really hurt
some people and people may die in health
care facilities hospitals because we
don't have enough nurses or health care
workers why have to make that decision
all of a sudden we could have planned
for that a long time ago and so I think
hopefully this is a wake-up call cos you
know nobody I think really believed this
I got a tape you know the market today
as you know on this particular day
crashed badly and you know I think that
up until 10 days ago the market didn't
even think this was a possibility they
just if you look at it was flying high
on Friday I did a briefing for over 400
major financial investors around the
world and you know I you know how I'm
talking to you right now you know I'm
not trying to be scary I'm just trying
to tell the facts and make sure people
understand it the questions I got from
these people almost remind me of a
six-year-old who was afraid to have to
go throughout a dark or dark hallway you
know and and and I thought I actually
said to friends and colleagues Friday
night I said you know what Monday's
markets not gonna look good because I
could sear the fear in these people okay
well we shouldn't be there we should be
what are we going to do we have a
problem you know it's like a forest fire
whatever we got a problem what are gonna
do about it financially how we gonna get
through this you know where are we gonna
go with it no plans again it's caught
everybody by surprise I mean you are the
one of the few people that wanted to
deal with this issue you know we set
this up several weeks ago yeah you guys
saw it coming you know and and I think
that's where the country hasn't seen it
now they're getting it well I'm paranoid
[Laughter]
[Applause]